[Music]
every year science chooses one fantastic
discovery as its breakthrough of the
year
before we get to it here are a few of
the runners up
[Music]
dna from fossils has transformed what we
know about evolution
now scientists are digging up dna from
an entirely different place
the soil itself
in spain dna extracted from a cave floor
revealed that three groups of
neanderthals had once occupied it and
only one remained at the end of the last
ice age
in a cave in the country of georgia
scientists found a female genome from a
previously unknown line of neanderthals
and in another cave in northern mexico
twelve thousand-year-old dna from four
black bears revealed that their
descendants migrated to alaska as the
climate warmed
new techniques that sift nuclear dna
from ancient soil made these findings
possible as the method spreads expect
many more answers to questions about
earth's ancient past
nasa's insight spacecraft is bringing
the interior of mars into focus like
never before
soon after its 2018 arrival the lander
detected a handful of mars quakes these
underground tremors revealed that the
thin martian crust has at least two
layers maybe as many as three
that thin shell would have made it easy
for the planet to shed heat early in its
history
one layer down mars mantle is also
thinner than expected lacking an
insulating lower half at the planet's
center is a huge liquid nickel iron core
but insight is running out of time it
has just a few months to hear more
quakes before martian dust covers its
solar panels and it powers down forever
in 2021 psychedelic drugs got a big
boost in mainstream medicine one major
study found that patients with
post-traumatic stress disorder improved
so much on the drug mdma and talk
therapy that two-thirds no longer had
the disorder after two months
the results brought excitement and
caution
nearly all participants correctly
guessed that they had received the drug
rather than the placebo perhaps due to
its psychoactive effects that might have
enhanced their expectations and their
odds of improving still if another
ongoing study can confirm these results
the treatment may be up for approval by
the u.s food and drug administration as
early as 2023
a new weapon is joining the fight
against covid19
anti-viral pills that can prevent
symptoms and death if taken early enough
this fall drug makers pfizer and merck
released clinical trial results still
under peer review that hinted at early
success
merck's antiviral reduced the risk of
hospitalization or death by 30 percent
in high unvaccinated individuals
meanwhile pfizer's two-drug approach
reduced hospitalization by 89
in the same group
there are concerns that the results may
not be as good as they appear and that
off-target effects in merck's pill could
cause troublesome mutations
the pills are also no replacement for a
vaccine
but if they become widely available they
could reduce death blunt breakthrough
infections and even cut transmission of
sars kovi 2 worldwide
and now the breakthrough of the year
for more than 50 years scientists have
tried to understand how proteins the
building blocks of biology transform
from simple chains of amino acids into
precisely folded 3d structures those
structures determine how proteins
interact with other molecules and could
reveal everything from unknown drug
targets to new insights into basic
biology
this year the power of artificial
intelligence improved those predictions
by magnitudes
before ai entered the scene scientists
used experimental techniques to map
proteins atom by atom researchers have
used these methods to uncover the
structures of more than 180 000 proteins
but such work is slow and expensive
to speed things up scientists started
using computers to predict the shapes
that proteins might take for the last
two decades those predictions have
gotten better but they still have room
for improvement
then ai changed everything alpha fold a
program developed by google's sister
company deepmind outshone every team at
a major competition in 2018
and in 2020 alpha fold 2 showed that it
could predict proteins as well as
experimental techniques a major
milestone and this year researchers at
deepmind solved
350 000 human protein structures 44 of
all known human proteins and a really
good fraction of the 200 million thought
to exist
other researchers are using ai to
predict how proteins come together and
interact for a wide variety of
applications even now alpha fold 2 is
modeling the spike protein in the new
omicron variant of sars cov2 and
scientists are eagerly awaiting results
[Music]
you